hi everyone i'm award winning actor
rayne wilson
and i'm new york times bestselling
author reza aslan and we are just so
excited to tell you
all about the amazing podcast we're
doing with cast media called
metaphysical milkshake that's right we
sit down with some of the most
brilliant provocative minds of our
generation to try to answer some of
life's most profound questions
we go deep we get weird and we search
for the meaning of life along the way
and i actually we just posted about this
on twitter with a zoom link so
that fans can ask us anything they want
about our new podcast
yeah so uh fire it away all right let's
do this
hi rayne i just have to say i am so
excited that you're doing an office
rewatch podcast just like the office
ladies
i cannot wait um and my question is why
did jim always look at the camera
thanks okay right well just to clarify
uh
this is not an office rewatch
show right right so this is metaphysical
milkshake
and in this podcast we sit down with
like you know
um interesting people intellectual
heavyweights people like malcolm
gladwell
and adam grant elizabeth colbert and we
chatted with uh beloved actress
and neuroscientist mayam bialik on
whether or not religion is still
relevant in 2021
oh yeah that was a good one that was a
really good one thanks for the question
but again not an office rewatch show so
next question let's let's roll it hi
dwight
um i'm just so excited to hear
all the inside stories about working at
dunder mifflin
my question is did you and angela
ever date in real life thank you
okay um no okay
i'm i'm a happily married man i i
haven't never dated angela
you know the thing is is that i knew
this was gonna happen i knew that as
soon as i signed on
to do a podcast with you rayne that this
is exactly the kind of stuff that we
were going to have today
hey hey hey what do you want from me
reza it's not my fault i was on the
seinfeld of my generation and i'm
beloved by millions
it says here that the next question is
for you oh
okay yeah so let's let's roll the video
tape on that here we go
all right hi reza i'm a huge fan of your
work
i love your book zealot so
as a zealot of the office
can you ask reign oh my god what his
favorite prank that jim did on him was
okay that's it i can't i can't do this
i'm sorry
no all right thanks everyone
[Music]
cats